Heather McDonald is the Thomas W Smith
fellow the Manhattan Institute and a
contributing editor of city journal she
holds a BA in English from Yale
graduating with a Mellon fellowship to
Cambridge University where she earned an
MA in English and studied in Italy
through a Clare College study grant she
also holds a JD from Stanford University
Law School miss McDonald is the author
of several books including our cops
racist as well as forthcoming the war on
cops how the new attack on law and order
makes everyone less safe please join me
in welcoming Heather McDonald well thank
you so much this is a great great honor
to be at Hillsdale Thank You Matthew I
appreciate the introduction Hillsdale is
obviously a premier institution for
preserving and passing on constitutional
principles and his Matthew mentioned
the founders understood the probably the
greatest achievement of Western
civilization is the rule of law that
achievement is presently at risk and
today I want to lay out the reasons why
since summer 2014 a protest movement
known as black lives matter has
convulsed the nation triggered by the
police shooting of Michael Brown in
Ferguson Missouri in August 2014 the
black lives matter movement holds that
racist officers are the greatest threat
facing young black men today this belief
has triggered riots Dian's the murder
and attempted murder of police officers
a campaign to eliminate traditional
grand jury proceedings when officers use
lethal force and a Presidential Task
Force on policing even though the US
Justice Department has resoundingly
disproven the lie that a Pacific Michael
Brown was shot in cold blood while
trying to surrender Brown is still
venerated as a martyr
and now officers are backing off of
proactive policing under the relentless
venom directed at them on the street and
in the media as a result violent crime
is on the rise the need is urgent
therefore to examine the black lives
movement central thesis that the police
are the greatest threat facing young
black men today I'm going to propose to
counter hypotheses first that there is
no government agency more dedicated to
the proposition that black lives matter
than the police and second that we have
been talking about alleged police racism
over the last 20 years in order not to
talk about a far larger problem black on
black crime now let's be clear at the
onset police have an in defeasible
obligation to treat everyone with
courtesy and respect and within the
confines of the law too often officers
developed a hardened obnoxious attitude
it is also the case that being stopped
when you were innocent of any wrongdoing
is infuriating humiliating and sometimes
terrifying and needless to say every
unjustified police shooting of an
unarmed civilian is a stomach-churning
tragedy given the appalling history of
racism in this country and the
complicity of the police in that history
police shootings of black men are
particularly and understandably fraught
that history informs how many people
view the police
but however intolerable and inexcusable
every act of police brutality is and
while we need to make sure that the
police are properly trained in the
Constitution and in courtesy and respect
there is a larger reality behind the
issue of policing crime and race that
remains a taboo topic the problem on
black and black crime is an
uncomfortable truth but unless we
acknowledge it we won't get very far
our standing patterns of policing every
year approximately six thousand blacks
are murdered that's a number higher than
white and Hispanic murder victims
combined even though blacks are only 13%
of the national population
blacks of all ages are killed at six
times the rate of whites and Hispanics
combined in Los Angeles a typical City
blacks between the ages of 20 and 24
diet are eight twenty to thirty times
the national mean who's killing them
not white civilians and not the police
but other blacks the astronomical black
death by homicide rate is a function of
the black crime rate black males between
the ages of 14 and 17 commit homicide at
ten times the rate of white and Hispanic
male teenagers combined black males of
all ages commit homicide at eight times
the rate of whites and Hispanics and
twelve times the rate of whites alone
the police could end all use of lethal
force tomorrow and it would have at most
a negligible effect on the black death
by homicide rate
moreover the percentage of blacks among
civilians killed by the police
26% is far less than what the black
crime rate would predict since police
shootings are going to occur most often
in neighborhoods where cops are
confronting violent armed criminals and
people resisting arrest
40% of all cop killers over the last
decade have been black even though again
blacks are only 13% of the national
population standard anti-cop ideology
whether emanating from the ACLU or the
University holds the law enforcement
actions are racist if they don't mirror
population data New York City
illustrates why this benchmarking rule
is so misguided blacks are 23% of New
York City's population but they commit
75% of all shootings 70% of all
robberies and 66% of all violent crime
ad Hispanic shootings and you count
account for 98 percent of all illegal
gunfire in the city this means that
every time the police are called out on
a shots fired call they are inevitably
going to minority neighborhoods and
looking for minority suspects the police
don't wish for this they hope against
hope every time they're called out that
for once they will be confronting a
white suspect but the numbers are in
there against them whites in New York
City are about 3334 percent of the
population they commit 2 percent of all
shootings and 4% of all robberies these
disparities are mirrored in City after
City now this incidence of crime means
that innocent black men have a much
higher chance of being stopped by the
police because they match the
subscription of a suspect than white men
now who are some of the victims of
elevated urban crime on March 11th 2015
as protesters were once again converging
on the Ferguson Police Department
demanding the resignation of the entire
department a six-year-old boy named
Marcus Johnson was gunned down a few
miles away in a st. Louis Park the
victim of a drive-by shooting
no one protested his killing
al Sharpton didn't show up to demand a
federal investigation few people outside
of his immediate community even know his
name
last year in BO
Baltimore ten children under the age of
ten were gunned down and drive-by
shootings in Cleveland in September of
2015
three children five and younger were
gunned down in drive-by shootings in
November a nine year old in Chicago was
lured into an alley and killed by his
father's gang enemies the father refused
to cooperate with the police
in August 2015 a nine-year-old girl was
doing her homework in her mother's
bedroom and was killed by a bullet that
penetrated the house such mindless
violence seems almost to be regarded as
normal given the lack of attention it
would receive from the same people who
would be out in droves if any of those
victims had been shot by a police
officer as horrific as such shootings
are crime rates were much higher 20
years ago in New York City in 1990 for
example there were 2245 homicides in
2014 there were 333 a drop of 85% New
York's crime drop is the steepest in the
nation but crime has fallen at a
historic rate nationwide as well by
about 40 percent since the early 1990s
the greatest beneficiaries of that crime
drop have been minorities in New York
over 10,000 minority males are alive
today who would have been dead had
homicide rates remained at their early
1990s levels what is behind this
historic crime drop a policing
revolution that began in New York City
and spread nationally starting in 1994
the NYPD top brass embraced the radical
idea that the police can actually
prevent crime not just respond to it
they started obsessively gathering and
analyzing crime data on a daily and
eventually an hourly basis they looked
for patterns and strategized about
tactics to try to
well crime outbreaks as they were
emerging equally importantly for the
first time they held commanders actually
accountable for what was happening in
their jurisdictions department leaders
started meeting on a weekly basis with
precinct commanders to grill them on
crime patterns on their watch these
weekly accountability sessions came to
be known as CompStat they were ruthless
high-tension affairs
sometimes chairs were thrown because the
emotions and stakes were so high if
commander was not fully informed about
every local crime outbreak and ready
with a strategy to combat it his career
was in severe jeopardy ComStat created a
sense of urgency about crime-fighting
that has never left the NYPD for decades
the traditional rap against the police
was that they ignored crime in minority
neighborhoods ComStat keeps the police
focused like a laser beam on where
people are most being victimized and
that's in minority communities ComStat
spread nationwide departments across the
country now send officers to emerging
crime spots to try to interrupt criminal
behavior before it happens no other
government program has come close to
data-driven policing successes in
economic stimulus welfare forget about
it if you want to turn communities
around you have got to bring down crime
in New York City businesses that had
shunned previously drug infested
neighborhoods now set up shop they're
offering residents choice and shopping
and jobs for local workers senior
citizens felt safe to go out to the
store or the post office to pick up
their Social Security check
children could ride their bikes on
sidewalks without their mothers worried
that they would be shot but the crime
victories of the last two decades are
now in jeopardy thanks to the falsehoods
of the black lives matter movement there
are signs that law and/or
and the moral support for such order are
breaking down police operating in
inner-city neighborhoods now find
themselves routinely surrounded by
cursing cheering crowds when they make a
pedestrian stop or try to arrest a
suspect
sometimes bottles and rocks are thrown
cops are worried about becoming the
latest racist top of the week and
possibly living losing their livelihood
thanks to an incomplete cellphone video
it inevitably fails to show the
antecedents to their own use of force
officer use of force is never lovely to
see but the public is clueless about how
hard it is to subdue somebody who is
determined to resist arrest cops will
tell you can take five to six officers
as a result of the anti cop campaign of
the last two years and the resulting
pushback on the streets
officers in urban areas are cutting back
on precisely the type of policing that
is responsible for our crime drop and
that is pedestrian stops and low-level
enforcement of what is known as broken
windows type of fences those low-level
quality-of-life misdemeanors police
officers of course are continuing to
rush to 911 there's already been a
victim but responding after the fact is
not how you bring crime down you bring
crime down by intervening before it
happens when it comes to making that
discretionary stop getting out of your
car at 1:00 a.m. for example when
there's somebody hitching up his
waistband on a known drug corner
officers are telling each other you'd
have to be crazy to get out of your car
cops are human and when they are
repeatedly told that they are racist for
stopping and questioning suspicious
individuals in high crime areas at some
point they're going to do less of those
stops that is both understandable and in
a sense how it's
poster work policing is political if a
powerful political bloc has denied the
legitimacy of assertive policing then
we're going to get less of it but the
people demanding that the police back
off are by no means representative of
the entire black community go to any
police neighborhood meeting in Harlem
central Brooklyn or South Central LA and
you're going to hear some variant of the
following requests we want the dealers
off the corner you arrest them and
they're back the next day they're kids
hanging out on my stoop why can't you
arrest them for loitering the cops have
to say well we have this constitutional
precedent that says we can't do that
anymore but we'll at least talk to them
or I smell weed in my hallway why can't
you do something I met an elder cancer
amputee in the Mount Hope section of the
Bronx who was terrified to go into her
Lobby because of the kids trespassing
there and selling drugs
the only time she felt safe was when the
police were there please Jesus
she said send more police the irony is
that the police cannot respond to these
heartfelt requests for Public Order
without generating the very stop data
that can be used against them by the
ACLU or the Justice Department in
another racial profiling lawsuit
unfortunately when officers back off in
high crime neighborhoods crime shoots
through the roof the country is in the
midst of the first sustained violent
crime spike in two decades murders rose
nearly 17 percent in the nation's 50
largest cities in 2015 and it was in
cities with large black populations
where the violence increased the most
Baltimore's per capita homicide rate
last year was the highest in its history
Washington DC ended 2015 with a 54%
increase in murders Minneapolis was up
61 percent in homicides
and in Chicago where pedestrian stops
are down by 90% thanks to the anti cop
crusade shootings were up 80 percent in
March through March 2016 I first
identified the violent crime increase in
May 2015 and dubbed it the Ferguson
effect my diagnosis set off a firestorm
of controversy on the anti cop left and
in criminology circles
despite that furor FBI director James
Comey confirmed the Ferguson effect in a
speech at the University of Chicago Law
School last October and was promptly
taken to the woodshed by place by
President Barack Obama for doing so
Obama had the temerity to accuse his own
FBI director of cherry-picking data and
having a political agenda now the idea
that President Obama knows more about
policing and what's happening on the
streets than the FBI director is of
course ludicrous but Comey needed to be
taken down by the President and by his
press secretary Josh earnest because to
recognize the connection between
proactive policing and Public Safety
undermines the entire premise of the
anti cop left the overwhelming majority
of victims in the current crime increase
are as usual lack as are their
assailants but police officers are
coming under attack as well the number
of officers killed in shootings more
than doubled during the first three
months of 2016
officers are second-guessing themselves
about the use of force because they're
so worried about being caught on a video
and being dubbed as racist but it turns
out that officers are at much greater
risk from blacks and unarmed blacks are
from police officers and I'm the first
that has done this calculation but over
the last decade it turns out that an
officer's chance of getting killed by a
black has been
eighteen point five times higher than
the chance of an unarmed black getting
killed by a police officer now I don't
know what will end the current frenzy
against the police Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders are continuing President
Obama's race-based Kalymnos against the
criminal justice system arguing that the
criminal justice system is shot through
with bias and that it treats
similarly situation whites and blacks
differently this claim is false and
dangerous
criminologists have spent decades trying
to come up with evidence of racial bias
in the criminal justice system and the
honest ones have been forced to
acknowledge time and again that the
over-representation of blacks in prison
is due to their elevated crime rates not
to any discrimination on the part of
officers prosecutors judges or juries
but this claim undermines respect for
officers increases the chance of a
suspect resisting arrest
which puts everybody's lives at risk Ted
Cruz has done some push back against the
war on cops Trump less so it should be a
much broader campaign thing we've been
in this situation before in the 1960s
and early 1970s black and white radicals
regularly directed hatred and occasional
violence against the against the police
the difference today is that anti-cop
ideology is embraced at the highest
reaches of the establishment by the
president is Attorney General college
presidents Foundation heads and the
press we are playing with fire and if it
keeps spreading it will be hard to put
out thank you very much
the black and black on black prime is it
mostly gang-related the murder right is
it the majority is gangs yes it's it's
it's it's just the most insanely
mindless issues of disrespect and and
short fuses where people feel like
somebody disrespected them on Facebook
and the shootings come out and then you
get a retaliatory cycle the people
who've been denying the Ferguson effect
they're trying desperately to come up
with some other explanation other than
police backing off for these crime
increases uh and they'll say well
there's more illegal gangs drugs out
there or more drugs more guns nothing
else has changed and what has changes
the police officers backing off and
embolden criminals oh yeah
I think and if not all you
my video Lee you didn't mention
something that had started in New York
as a policing tactic stop and frisk stop
asked and frisk I think is the total
name would you comment on that and
especially the way it's been squashed by
the politicians of New York well it's a
tool obviously that has been around
officially since the 1960s when the
Supreme Court decided the case of Terry
versus Ohio which acknowledged that
there is a police power to temporarily
stop somebody and in theory hold them in
custody short of making an arrest to
make an arrest requires probable cause
to believe that a crime is underway or
about to occur which is a decent
threshold of of an officer's suspicion
the cops wanted something short of that
that would allow them to just at least
question somebody and and so this power
that is known as the Terry power came
into existence which said if you have
reasonable suspicion which is less than
probable cause to think that this person
may be up to no good for instance let's
say there's been a string of car
robberies car thefts in a neighborhood
and the police see somebody walking down
the street trying door handles that's
probably not enough to arrest that
person for for stealing a car but it
given the totality of circumstances of
you know time place and manner the
officer probably has reasonable
suspicion to ask that person a few
questions and during that time the
person is not free to leave that's known
as a custodial stop so this is our stop
question and you rightly say frisk is
only in New York City about 50% of any
stops actually resulted in a frisk it's
usually just questioning so this is a
power
the officers have had and of course
before the Supreme Court recognized this
power as constitutional and something
that cops could do it's still something
that officers have long done to use
their street knowledge to try and
intervene but in New York City uh it
became more of a concerted effort to try
and get guns off the street and not just
guns but to intervene in suspicious
behavior and it worked you know the
results speak for themselves uh we've
have criminals on tape saying I'm not
going into Brooklyn because they have
that stop thing there uh people we have
on tape and and criminals told the
police they stopped carrying guns
personally because of the risk of
getting stopped and they would instead
have a communal hiding place now that's
not ideal obviously ideally they don't
have guns at all but at least were
ratcheting down a little bit so they
actually have to go to the underneath
the mailbox or go to the gutter to get
their gun having a few moments of pause
in a street confrontation to cool things
down helps it's better than if somebody
actually is packing heat um so this was
a a tool that discouraged gun caring and
it works but it was it's been the
subject of decades of litigation and in
New York City we had a trilogy of
lawsuits a unholy alliance between our
left wing anti-cop advocacy groups like
the New York Civil Liberties Union
legally and of course the big law firms
Covington and Burling Paul Weiss that
were sending in their pro bono attorneys
to say the cops
yep make trespass stops in the Bronx
these are these are illegal and
oppressive uh these are Covington and
Burling attorneys who have doormen
telling people in these minority
neighborhoods that have no doormen that
they can't have the cops making stops
you would think if there had been this
epidemic of illegal stops at the ACLU
and the Legal Aid Society would have
their pick of plaintiffs that had been
victimized by the police the named
plaintiffs in these class-action
lawsuits were unbelievable
but these huge criminal records one of
them has just been indicted federally
for stomping a teen to death
others had huge drug histories gang
members this is who they got for their
name plaintiffs and then of course they
have that huge class actions so so stop
czar way down in New York City
95% shootings and homicides were
shooting through the roof in the first
half of 2015 our Commissioner William
Bratton and Mayor Bill DeBlasio were
freaking out because any New York mayor
now knows that he has one obligation
that's to keep crime down because
Giuliani showed it can be done and if
you can't match that you're out so what
Bratton did was basically throw bodies
at the problem he has the luxury of
having the biggest Police Department in
the country per capita and absolute
numbers so we just got them they're not
doing stops but they're just standing
using command presence and that put a
lid on things other departments have not
been so lucky again
Chicago stops our way down and they are
engaged in a constant bloodbath
Baltimore after the Freddie gray
incident stops and and low-level arrest
went way down and they
they're at their highest per capita rate
in history 40 in July they had 45 people
killed 42 of them black the rest
undoubtedly Hispanic when when the
police back off again the criminals
become emboldened yes um uh George or
once said that at an age of deceit
telling the truth is a revolutionary act
and I'm really but telling the truth is
a revolutionary act and and I'm struck
by your style and the fact that you're
giving a very frank appraisal in public
about these problems you're not supposed
to be able to do that today I mean we're
not as we're not the Soviet Union but we
you know it's still bad enough yeah and
I'm just curious this is almost a
personal question but nevertheless I'm
curious how do you manage to do this
without ending your career
without what and in your career I mean
how do you like I mean how do you get
away with this well I I just I can't
stand idiocy and I can't stand deception
so I am it's just I have to but I have
been doxxed which is a term I didn't
know about before by the black lives
matter movement which published my home
address and and home phone number on the
web for an article well it was an
amazing situation the San Francisco
Police Department
apparently in one of their precinct
houses somebody published a or posted a
Wall Street Journal op-ed I'd had on the
midst of the black lives matter movement
well the San Francisco Examiner got wind
of this and decided that this was like
completely an a racist act on the part
of the San Francisco Police Department
and they had an article about this with
pictures of the of the op-ed on their
bulletin board which was great you know
publicity for me but this this went
viral this San Francisco Examiner
article and as a result my personal
information was was put out there so but
I'm I mean any risk to
much less than what's what's going on
now in in inner-city areas thanks to the
cops backing off and that's that's the
more important problem talk about how
they talk about
has done more the war on police but I
lobby for a major law enforcement
organization and his record on law
enforcement issues is the worst or one
of the worst in the capital I mean I
just don't see how he's done more for
police when he hasn't really done
anything for us so far this Congress hmm
well I I don't know about that we've got
his chief of staff here can address that
but um I I know that he's been on the
surveillance issue and mass data perhaps
surprisingly more libertarian on that
but I think on street level urban
policing I know that he did a hearing in
a subcommittee of the of the Senate
Judiciary Committee a few months ago on
the war on cops so in so that's my
exposure to it and I know that he on the
campaign trail he has spoken about this
but again it needs to be spoken about
much more so I didn't know about that I
can speak this for my heart and what
I've experienced 40 police officers I
asked you were all having your handgun
out on the trigger and did not shoot
they had lawful and none of them had
department had thousand men in it and I
maybe know three that user and gun
during their entire career that's a stat
you know I had one other thing just got
back from a prison ministry and I the
leader prison ministry I called 100 cops
up and asked for donations 75 percent 75
in gave money prison
you can add those stats tear yeah no I
mean it's just the demonization and the
ignorance is just unbelievable and I'm
thinking we're talking about the cops
we've been having this conversation
about the cops instead of the daily
bloodshed that's going on it's
absolutely insane but yes I wrote I
wrote an article about the police
training in in New York City the Academy
these kids they want to help the
community they believe officers again
they're getting spat upon and yet they
will tell you again and again the good
people of the community support me they
hold on to that belief with utter fervor
and they're they're out there because
they believe that everybody has a right
to freedom from fear um and and it's
just it's it's tragic to me that
officers have to bear the knowledge of
the social breakdown of the inner city
because what's driving black crime of
course is the breakdown of the black
family when you have 73 percent out of
wedlock rate nationally and in places
like Baltimore you know areas it's it's
closer to 95 percent that is
civilizational catastrophe you you
cannot expect society to survive when
fathers are routinely regarded as
utterly superfluous but the cops are the
next best thing and and the and the
officers see this problem and yet they
can't talk about it and nobody else will
talk about it and they're bearing that
knowledge on their shoulders and it's
quite oppressive sir you
United States Capitol Police officer
retired um also a former vice mayor of
the city of Alexandria Virginia um being
a police officer and I work with young
people in the city of Alexandria I'm
also a what you call substitute teacher
in the Alexandria school system and I
specialize in working with the adjuvant
I'll detention facility in the juvenile
detention facility but what I wanted to
say to you is everything that you're
saying is absolutely on point as a
matter of fact when I looked around a
room I want to see how many African
Americans were here and Wow
you know for me it's like outstanding
you know uh and what I mean by that is
what you're saying is outstanding and
it's directly on point and I understand
what you were saying to about Ted Cruz
he has a project that he's trying to
work with it's called Project awakening
where where he wants to what he wants to
do is he wants to use business community
also the clergy to go in and work with
young african-american males to turn
that around our problem in the
african-american community is we no
longer have fathers in the community and
that's the main thing is the family so
it is rebuilding the family and when
you're working through that and you're
working with the clergy and you're also
working with businesses to do that
around and get the government out once
we get the government out of it and we
work with the communities and work with
clergy and business people you'll see a
change in the african-american community
but keep doing what you're doing thank
you so much I'm so honored and I would
say I will make one exception that the
police are the one agency where size
matters it's good to have police
officers because when you don't have
those informal social controls
unfortunately you're going to have to
rely on the police but I could not agree
with you more and we need to be able to
say that father's matter and we can't do
that anymore
mostly because of feminists who are
absolutely committed to the idea that
strong
can do it all including raising children
and of course there are many single
mothers who are working their hearts out
to raise law-abiding self-control
discipline children above all males and
and some are succeeding but the social
science evidence is about as
incontrovertible as it gets and I'm
preaching to the crowd I'm sure with
this audience but it to be raised in a
single-parent household is just numerous
strikes are against you as far as likely
ending up in in dropping out of school
being a teen mother and ending up in the
criminal justice system we you know the
Obama administration has popularized
this term the school to Prison Pipeline
as if there's just this vacuum that
comes out and arbitrarily sucks up black
boys and sticks them in prison from
school
totally circumventing behavior this is
the central as far as I'm concerned this
is the central divide between liberals
and conservatives liberals look at
social outcomes and they see large
structural forces of inequality
conservatives look at unequal outcomes
and they see behavior they see the
connection between behavioral personal
responsibility individual choices that
people have made and where they end up
and obviously when we're talking about a
crime this is a central problem as you
just see this as somehow this influenza
that comes into a neighborhood and
that's the way criminologist talk they
want to imply now a public health model
to thinking about crime as if it's just
like the Black Plague that comes in and
and a neighbor becomes we all have to be
criminals know it's it's individual
choices and above all the choice of a
father to stay with the mother and a
choice of a mother not to get pregnant
unless she is willing to have that male
as a husband so feminism is a big
problem and we are in a culture now that
systematically devalues males and this
is another
problem for civilization I don't know
where that's going to end up but I would
just like to put in a plug here for my
favorite non-governmental organization
uh which is the Boy Scouts short of
families the Boy Scouts intercity Boy
Scouts are a thing of beauty
they will make you weep to see the love
that goes into with these Scout masters
for these inner city boys learning to
tie their kerchief and trying to be neat
about it and developing a code of
chivalry this is what the Boy Scouts
provides is a code of male goodness that
is not otherwise accessible in our
culture so I would hope that we and of
course the Boy Scouts have been in the
crossfire of the gay rights movement
inner-city Scout troops are dying
because corporations corporate support
dried up because they're gay employees
said you can't support them it's a
homophobic institution as if some kid in
bedford-stuyvesant in a church basement
learning to tie knots gives a darn about
what their policy is on openly gay Scout
masters uh it was an act of utter
narcissism on the part of the gay rights
lobby so I would just again add that as
if you want if you have like money in
your pocket that's burning its way out
Boy Scouts is a great place to start mr.
McDonald thank you for your time today
so
okay miss McDonald thank you for your
time today
I just wanted to ask you about this
recent effort bouncing around on Capitol
Hill about so called sentencing reform
there seems to be this strange misguided
desire to let a lot of federal felons
out of prison under the guise that these
are all nonviolent low-level felony
offenders when the reality is they're
all traffickers and dealers I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about the myth that any drug crimes are
not violent crimes and are not part of
this greater problem we're seeing in
cities well first of all let's take the
really big myth which is that as mayor
last summer President Obama visited a
federal prison in Oklahoma and the
reporters were all gathering around and
I wanted as a response and he said well
there but for the grace of God go I and
the New York Times said yes a president
it's not too far of a leap from
President to federal prisoner well maybe
so I mean if we get Hillary Clinton who
knows but um but what they were
insinuating was that because we know
that President Obama smoked pot in
college and who knows how long beyond
that that he could have ended up in the
El Reno Correctional Facility for
smoking pot this is insane but the ACLU
has done a very good job of perpetuating
this myth you have to work really hard
to get into prison I mean really hard
it's a Lifetime Achievement Award for
persistence in criminal offending and to
end up in federal prison you have to be
a serious drug trafficker uh less than
1% of all federal drug prisoners are
there for possession and virtually all
of those possession cases have been pled
down from trafficking I take my cue from
the people in the communities that live
with open-air drug markets and what they
to the police is we want the dealers off
the streets I don't know how the police
are supposed to respond to that but if
you if you don't live in that situation
you don't know what it's like because
drug dealing is has always an implicit
threat of violence even if they're not
using guns at that moment their
territory is implicitly being controlled
by violence and people don't want it
federal sentencing reform to be honest
I'm willing to talk about tweaking the
mandatory minimum sentences because
they're all arbitrary it's not as if
there is some Platonic ideal for what a
cocaine sentence should be so if it's if
it's 20 years mandatory now for a
massive quantity that was if it had been
15 to begin with nobody would be
complaining about moving it from 20 to
15 so I'm not going to get too hot under
the collar about maybe revisiting some
of the federal penalties what I think is
more dangerous is the ideology that
underlies our current reform efforts
which is that the disproportionate
representation of blacks is in prison is
due to racism and not to criminal
offending and what we should be talking
about is how to get more black boys
fathers so they don't end up in federal
prison in the first place so I think I
think Matthew said that's thank you so
much I appreciate it
okay